foreign
[Music]
system for the molecular Diagnostics
so here's the auto length for Methodist
talk so firstly I will give you a brief
background of the macrophotic technology
and the quiz for technology for disease
Technologies
so then I will give you a three examples
uh three uh quiz for based uh passensing
technology for disease danglicity so
firstly I will talk about the
crispr-based macrophoretic technological
system for South African 2 detections
without the ND complex equipment
so secondly I will talk about our next
critical sensor technology which take
advantage the effect and
extension of the crispr theory to
improve the crispr detection performance
so lastly I will talk about our Crystal
based electrochemical sensor so we use
the electrical electric field to improve
and enrich the nucleic acid to improve
the detection sensitivity for critical
based fantastic
uh here's a brief background and the
motivation for our topic
so what if uh Microsoft Technology so
Microsoft chip also is called LeBron
chip so this is a device that integrates
several level functions on a single chip
like the red figures so typically for
the
biochemical test or biometric biomedical
experiment so it requires a multiple
technicians work together and it may be
take a few hours or half days to
complete the experiment here if we
develop some macrophotic attack mods we
can integrate it over this biomedical
experiment in this single chip we will
make the
biochemical reaction or detection
automatically complete in the device
compare existing technology the macro
fluorotic technology have some uh
Advantage fortunately it's a simple
rapid and this is a low cost easy to
operation technology so it's uh I have a
multiple integrated functions uh so a
macrophoretic technology is suitable for
point of care Diagnostics so this is a
way the one of the major applications
for the macrophoretic technology is for
point of care uh Technologies of the
disease
so here we talk about a little of the
point of care then glutix technology so
point of care test is a simple medical
uh detections that can perform at the uh
benefit so typically for the point of
care uh diagnostic device it should be
meet a huge criteria for instance uh it
should be affordable uh sensitive
specific user friendly rapid equipment
free and deliverable so because uh for
the point of care technology they have a
lot of advantage for disease uh
Technologies uh so uh there is um
unmet need for the developing countries
because for this developing countries
there's a lack of the funding of the
equipment or even uh uh uh clinical
chaos so there is um a clear need for
this uh developing countries but even in
the developed countries uh so there are
also is a need for Rapid uh point of
Care thank you thank you uh especially
since uh covid-19 pandemic as you know
we need some uh rapid kit for South
Korean two various detections when we
fetch the covid-19 pandemic
uh so so this is where where we are
interested uh develop some macro
fluorotic uh technology
for uh
so there are different methods for
instance uh you can detect the nuclear
acid by using the PCR technology or rtps
are technology so another method is the
antibody or antigen detections uh you
you can use the Immunology test like the
letter flow of the strip so for the
nucleic acid test you can achieve the
early detections uh before you have some
symptoms so and for the antibody
detections it take a few weeks or to get
the antibod which can detectable with
your immuno assay so this is why in the
in the hospital they use a piece of
technology or RTP technology to detect
the nucleic acid for the pathogen
detection like the subsequent 2 variable
yes
okay so the nucleic acid with uh
triglycerics is one of the most
sensitive and the specific tangolistics
approach uh because it detect the
specific nucleic acid sequence from the
pathogens
so there are different uh molecular
Technologies technology exists for
instance as I have mentioned the PCL
technology or rtpsr technology is a way
to use in the clinical lab for the
pathogen detections uh so the piece of
technology is considered the good
standard method for infections disease
detections but the PCL technology
typically require the expensive PCL
machine so which is not available at a
point of care test or in the summer
clinics so in recent 10 years so there's
more and more interested develop some as
a thermal amplification technology to
replace the PCL technology to detect the
nucleic acid for the molecular dangerous
for instance Loop mediated as a thermal
amplification like a lamp is one of the
most popular technology for the SS
thermal amplification of the pathogens
but the isothermal amplification uh you
know have some false positive signal so
this is not a divided for uh clinical
Technologies in recent years with the
development of the critical technology
and the move and the more research are
interested adapt the crisp technology
through the pathogen detections
so uh for the critical purpose uh by
sensing or nucleic acid detections so
there are a lot of Advantage uh so
firstly so this is a simple rapid group
of tests uh so they do not require a
very complex equipment so if you combine
the critical technology with the
isothermal amplifications so you can
achieve the highly sensitivity and the
specificity detections so for instance
there are different crypto technology
was a development so uh of among these
technology there are two major uh
technology
is when when is the Sherlock technology
which developed by the MIT researcher
they use the case study to detect the
nuclear acid and another technology is
called detector so detection methods I
use case travel a
amplification to improve the detection
sensitivity
and for the Crystal Bridge technology so
it's very simple and is ideally for
point of care Monica Diagnostics
but uh for the clipboard technology they
also have some detail Advantage uh for
instance so it require multiple
operations uh so for instance
pre-emplification of the SSM
amplification or crisprot detection so
which uh have some carry over
contamination concerns and they say oh
so still need the equipment or
instrument for instance the electrical
heaters so to address uh some issue we
develop different uh Crucible based uh
best sensing technology for uh
infections disease detections so here is
our mid money instrumented Christopher
based uh benefiting systems so here I
introduce a two uh devices so one is a
self-contained crisper based macro
fluorotic balancing existence another is
fair and extension crisper next Crystal
bad sensors
firstly I will introduce the crystal
based macro fluorotic balancing systems
for the source codeine 2 detections
so this is the design for our
self-contained macro fluorotic
technology systems as you see I in this
figure C so for this self-contained
Microsoft existence there are two parts
one part is the the heater case so this
here case have a hand warmer so this
hand warmer can hit the macro fluid chip
for the RPA amplification and the crisp
detections and the another part is the
self-contained macrophotic chip since
chip include different
reaction unit as you can see in the
figure B so they include the RPA
Chambers for the isothermal
amplification and the crisp chamber for
the detection so we also have the
collection chamber for sample mixing so
we include the letter flow strip for
visual detections so for the liquid of
solutions we please do the liquid in the
Barista so without any pipettings uh so
if this is the positive samples as you
can see in the figure d uh so uh in the
test line so you can see a very strong
signals so if this is a negative samples
you can see a very strong signal in the
control length
so this is the principle for our
self-contained macro Florida device so
this is a totally fully
self-contained device so there is no uh
cavity over uh contamination issue for
this uh device so this is the operation
of this uh dang lucidic systems so once
you introduce the sample into the RPA
Chambers so you can incubate uh this
macro vertical chip on the hand warmer
for 15 minutes so after that so you just
press the water water a priest this
official briefly will push the option
applicant to the crispr samples for the
crispr and cleavage so after 30 minutes
so you uh please uh press the um the
buffer Drifters so the uh the RP the
crisp uh product welcome to the
collection a collection chamber for the
letter flue detection so the over
process will take less than 60 minutes
so
the detection principle of the letter
flow test for the crispr uh production
so if this is a positive sample so you
can see a very strong signal in the test
length like the frequency uh showing and
the negative samples uh they have the
very strong signal that in the control
line
okay so here uh when we adapt the hand
warmer for the equation of the RPA
amplification and decrease the
detections so here we want to test
whether
this hand warmer can meet the the
amplification and the crisp detections
so we check the optimal reaction
temperature for rpe and the crispr so as
you can see uh in uh in the rpu
amplification the optimal temperature is
37 to 42 degrees and for the AEP Cliff
travel a and then we have the weather
optimal temperature from 25 to 48
degrees so here we test a different
ambient temperature from 50 to 15 to 35
degrees so as you can see with the
increase of the ambient temperature so
the wrapping time of the hand warmer
effective reduced for incidence when the
ambient temperature is 35 degrees so it
only takes two minutes
to reach the uh the 37 degrees for the
macrophobic chip so this is for the
artillery amplifications after 50
minutes of your incubations so next so
it will do the cliff based credit
reactions so from this test we can
figure out our hand warmer can work at a
very broad temperature ambulance
temperature so it's available for uh for
instrument free point of care then glue
sticks
so after we evaluate the heater
performance here we further detect the
analytical performance of this
self-contained macro resistance so we
detect the sensitivity so we can detect
100 copies of South equivalent tool very
only with this uh grief purpose
microfluetic device then we also
evaluate the specificity we detect the
soft Covington subscribing and the most
curving controls so only South Korean 2
samples show a strong
positive signals so it means our SC have
already a good specificity and this
sensitivity so once we evaluate the
analytical performance with our device
so we further detect the clinic example
for South Korean 2 detections so first
of all the uh we uh we use the rtpcr to
confirm uh whether which sample or
positive or negative so we run the
real-time RTP cell test so figure a
shows the secure volume of the rtpcr
result so
and the figure B is the end point of
fluorescent detection of the artificial
products so frequency assures the uh the
letter flow a test in our macrophotic
chip so as you can see uh in the
frequency we can directly detect our
positive sample except for example seven
uh so from figure a to the secure volume
of the sample 7 is 30
37 so the three key value is very high
it means the the South Korean who are
very only is very very low maybe less
than 100 copies so this is where we
cannot detect with our macro fluorotic
device so here we consider the rtpcr
method is a good standard uh technology
detections We compare it with our uh
macrophotic device so we can achieve the
sensitivity of uh 94 percent and the
expensive city are 100 percent so the
accuracy for our device is 96 percent uh
so this is our macrophone device uh for
South Korea tool detections so next I
will talk about the fifth and uh
extension uh crispr record next crisp or
pair sensor in our recent experiment so
we found uh extend the fair end of the
crispacion we can improve the Clipper
based detections so here we extend the
uh the verb end of the the Chris passion
to develop the fluorescent detection and
the letter flow detection
so before we adapt the uh the excitation
uh the only for crispr detections we
first optimize the crispr reaction
buffer system as you know there are
different uh buffer available uh in the
inep companies so here we test uh 10
buffer from the NEP we find the NEP
buffer full and The Cut Smart buffer I
have the best performance in our crisp
detections so next we evaluate the the
performance of different uh extended
crisp assembly for the next clip
detections as you can see uh with the
increase of the five and
quiz version so the forenses will
increase in the figure Africa
and we combine The Optimist buffer
system and extend uh effect and
um Theory we developed this next
critical essay so we compare the
conventional uh crisp detections as you
can see in the figure G so with our next
clip I see we get a really really strong
forensic signal with uh compare the uh
conventional crisp detections
so once we optimize our next uh crispr
SC so we further detect uh evaluate the
sensitivity so here uh we incubate uh
the quick direction for 10 minutes or 30
minutes as you you can see uh for our
next crisp detections after 10 minutes
incubation so you can detect a few
copies uh samples so just like 10
minutes 16 molars and for the
conventional crispr I see it can not and
then we also evaluate the performance of
the letter flow detection as shown in
the frequency so we can detect
um minus 10 minutes 70 molar of HP
reading with our next crypto sensors
so only take uh 10 minutes crispr
incubation it's second difference reduce
the detection tense
so here uh we evaluate the clinical
performance of our next crisp best
sensor so here we detect the HTTP
meeting a Target as you maybe know uh
the attribute English is one of the
major uh bear Market foods for the
cervical cancer and the other oral
cancers so here uh we use the cervical
swap cleaning sample uh as
um as a example to evaluate the
performance of our next crisp best
sensor we have detect uh 12 Clinic
samples include five positive samples
with both fluency detection and the
letter flow detections so as you can see
for the for the fluorescent detections
for positive sample they have a very
very strong Threat Signal and the
negative sample it does not for the
letter flow of which test for the
positive sample in the test line they
show various drone signals and for
negative sample they sure strong signal
in the control lamp so this uh next
critical test result is consistent with
the PCR has a result
okay so uh here I will switch to the
last topic uh I will introduce the
electrical field enhanced we call it efe
electrical chemical crisp or bad sensor
so here we use the electric electrical
field improve the Clipper with
detections uh as you know for the
electrical chemical detection so this is
a simple glucose and the powerful
technology for the nuclear acid or
pathogen detection so people could
technology so this electrochemical
detection method is well to use in the
best sensors and the grid plan watch
will provide a new uh strategy for
nucleic acid sensing so uh
so at this point so the current uh
Crucible boost electric chemical sensor
they need immobilize the electrochemical
proof on the surface of the electrons
for instance as you can see in the in
this figure so you need to First remove
this the electro uh active proof on the
surface of the electrodes so if this is
a positive samples so the active widget
uh Crystal quick travel will cut the
probe and they will release the electro
active probe so so in this case uh the
the electrochemical signal is very low
and if this is a negative sample through
the crisp Cliff driveway and then is not
activated we cannot cut the electro
active group so you you can get a very
strong electron chemical signal for the
negative samples so this is a current
election
published electrochemical sensors but
the issue is for the immobilization of
the electrochemical group is a
complicated and the tank consume process
so so here to address this issue we have
developed a
immobilization-free critical based
electrochemical sensor for the nucleic
acid detections so the unique part for
our
sensor is that we take advantage the
electrical field to enrich the nucleic
acid to improve the detection
sensitivity
so as you can see in the figure B uh so
uh or Target uh and the electrochemical
proof uh we are suspend uh homogeneous
in the solutions uh so once you apply
the past electrical field uh so because
the uh the DNA is a negative charged and
then if you apply the other electrical
field through the the thing we the thing
will absorbed on the possible charged
electrode surface and this can enrich
the nuclear acid and once the various
positive samples so the crisp and then
will be activated they will cut the
proof and release the uh the methylene
blue uh proof so because the maximum
group Loop is not charged so the USD on
the electrical electric surface and
therefore the uh for the negative
samples because the group is not cut so
and they collect the single strating I
think the single situating is negative
charge when you apply the negative
charge they will push the singular
single single strand thing away so for
the negative samples uh so the signal is
uh of the electrochemical detection is
already weak and for the positive
samples uh the electrical current is
really strong so this is the principle
for our electrical field enhanced
electrical chemical sensors
so firstly we evaluate the performance
of our clip sensor I use the
fluorescence group so as you can see if
we uh if we use the positive samples so
after 60 Minutes inclusions you can see
a strong fluorescence in the
electrochemical reaction Chambers and if
this is a negative samples so there's no
forenses in the electrochemical reaction
chamber and as I have mentioned in our
Crystal sensor we use the the past
Electric electrical fluid to improve the
detections so here we evaluate the
effect of the frequency of our
electrical free Arch so we change the uh
Franklin from 1 to 100 health so there
is no can use the change for the
fluorescent Direction in our crisp
reactions then we also evaluate the
effect of the peak to Peak amplitude for
this electrical field uh it's
interesting that when we increase the
amplitude the forensics will increase so
when we apply the the amplitude of 10
mini voltage we can get the strongest
fluency signal when we continue to
increase the the voltage so it will get
the air Bob so and the signal will
reduce so this this is where here we use
a 10 mid voltage for our clipboard based
electrochemical sensors
so finally uh here we also optimize the
electro active single strand dingly uh
maximum blue proof so as you can see
with the increase of the proof so the
background also increase but we find the
two macro molar single strength English
blue blue give a strong signal when we
subtract the the background so this is
the optim Optimus uh group constitutions
so here we compare the sensitivity for
this crisp by sensor with and without
apply the electrical field as you can
see for the crisp Benson's dancers with
a electrical field they show 110 hair
sensitivity compare the the sensor
without electrical field so this is
where we apply this uh Electric
electrical field for our bare sensor so
after we confirmed the performance so
here we evaluate the the detection of
the HPV DNA uh in the clinical samples
so here we test six uh cleaning sample
includes a full positive samples so all
a positive sample can detect about our
uh our crypto priest Electro bear
sensors
uh so uh this is the crystal based basis
for the uh for the attribute detections
okay so uh here I just want to make a
brief conclusion so we have a brief
introduce the macro floating technology
and the crisp uh technology for the best
sensing so when we integrated the crisp
detection with macrophoretic Device we
can develop a self-contained quiz
purposed uh best sensor for South Korean
2 detections uh so and we also talk
about to extend the Fab end of Crystal
Theory to develop a next critical best
sensor to improve the detection
sensitivity then we talk about apply the
soft electrical field
in which the nuclear acid developed a
immobility
immobilization-free electrochemical
crisp by sensor for HPV detection in the
clinical samples
uh here I wanted to thank my lab member
for their how to work in the lab and I
wanted to thank the collaborator in our
project so finally I want to thank the
financial support from English and the
ucom
so uh thank you so much uh I am really
happy to answer any questions